- I had one heckler, but I was in a parade
as Miss Oklahoma City University.
- Wow, that, you got to that so fast,
and don't do your water drink,
'cause I know your game.
You're not on Charlie Rose.
(sign creaks)
(upbeat music)
- A man yelled out, I was sitting,
sitting, not even standing,
on a back of a car,
waiting, and he goes, "You're short!"
I thought, well A, newsflash,
I know, and B,
couldn't you have thought
of a better heckle?
- I typically get, like, "Shut up,
"you annoying (bleep) tour."
(gasp)
Or, "Your smelly hole is
like a fish market," and--
- You get that yelled at you? That's mean.
- Yes, but what's funny is,
I sometimes will get it from gay audiences
as an endearment, like
(laughter)
"Hey diva, you're my
favorite smelly gash."
To which I say, "Thank you."
And I'm very pro-LGBT, as you are as well.
- Of course, but my gays
will be like, "Brava, diva!"
That's the difference.
- My gays are like,
"Fierce, stinky hole, love your gash."
And you know what?
That is okay.
- [Kristin] You accept it.
- [Kathy] I do.
If a straight guy said that to me,
by the way, I'd be livid.
- So tonight, when you're on stage,
should I go, "I love
you, you stinky whore!"
- Yeah, that's completely acceptable.
- You think anyone will know it's me?
- I think if you sing it
they might know it's you.
- I love you, you stinky whore.
- Even you make it sound beautiful.
- Thank you.
That's good, that's enough.
- All right, that's enough.
- What's your cup say?
- My cup says, "LOL."
- Mine says, "Oh my God," or, "OMG."
What is the red thing? Oh, that's hot.
- That's the hot water, I think.